>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Thank you so much
for coming this morning.
My name is Maria Pallante.
I'm the United States Register
of Copyrights, and on behalf
of the U.S. Copyright
Office, I want to welcome you
to my favorite day of
the year, World IP Day.
This year's theme as given to us
by the World Intellectual
Property Organization is
"Digital Creativity:
Culture Reimagined."
It's a great theme.
It speaks to a lot of things.
It speaks to balance.
It speaks to collaboration,
and it speaks to the fact
that the digital revolution
has changed the way
that people create as well.
And for the fifth year, I'm
very proud and pleased to say
that we are hosting
the Copyright Alliance.
Standing here with me
is Keith Kupferschmid --
who will speak in a moment --
who is the head of the
Copyright Alliance.
And as usual, the Copyright
Alliance has brought
to us just an extraordinary
lineup of creators.
And we will get out of
the way as fast as we can
so that you can enjoy
your morning with them.
But, before we do that, I would
like Keith to say a few words
about the Copyright Alliance.
>> Well, good morning,
everybody.
It's also one of my
favorite days of the year.
My son happens to be
born on this day as well,
so that has something
to do with it.
So I am the new CEO of
the Copyright Alliance.
Since the Copyright Alliance has
joined in the Copyright Office
in this event for the past five
years, many of you are probably
at least a little bit
familiar with Alliance,
but let me describe a little bit
of what we do and who we are.
We represent over 15,000
individual creators
and organizations from all
different copyright disciplines,
from movies, music,
literary works, software,
photography, the
arts, and so on.
Our objective is to promote
and preserve the copyright law
and to protect creators so that
they can do what they do best,
which is to create.
It's a pleasure to be back
here at the Copyright Office
where I worked as a Policy
Planning Advisor many,
many, many years ago.
Back then, I can recall being
very impressed by the commitment
and passion of the
Copyright Office staff.
As I returned to the Office
in a different capacity,
it's apparent that
this commitment
and dedication continues
to be the case today.
The copyright community is very,
very fortunate to have an office
that is staffed with
such devoted
and enthusiastic workforce
headed by the great leadership
of Register Pallante and
her legal and policy team,
who I see sort of scattered
about the audience here.
So, of course, it goes
without saying that we
at the Copyright
Alliance are thrilled
to be joining the
Copyright Office
in putting together what
will be a fantastic event.
Trust me on this one.
It's going to be fantastic.
And now, another thing you
should know about me is
that I have no creative talent.
I can't sing.
I can't play an instrument.
I can't act, and I
certainly don't code.
And my idea of creative
writing is putting a contraction
in a legal brief.
So I consider myself
very fortunate
to be working alongside
and for thousands
of very unbelievably talented
people, individual performers,
video game developers,
photographers, songwriters,
artists, directors, authors,
journalists, and
the list goes on.
And that list includes
today's panelists.
The group of the panelists
that we have here today are
truly the poster children
for creativity and innovation.
On Capitol Hill,
the press and others
like to pit the copyright
community
against the tech community.
Like the Game of Thrones,
this makes for a very
compelling story,
but really has no
basis in reality.
The creative community is
partners and collaborators
with the technology community.
In many instances,
individual creators
and organizations are playing
dual roles, both as creators
of copyrighted works and
as technology innovators
who themselves develop new
technologies or who adopt
and drive demand for
technologies necessary
to the creation and
distribution of their works.
There are no better
examples of this
than the panelists
we have here today.
Although I don't have any
creative talents myself,
as the head of the
Copyright Alliance, it is my
and my staff's responsibility
to use our legal expertise
to make sure these
creators can make the most
out of their talents.
In short, my job is to make
sure creators can do their job
and get paid for it.
I want to briefly raise
three things that we can do
to help these creators.
The first is to modernize
the U.S. Copyright Office.
Few government offices are
more important to the growth
of creativity and commercial
activity in the United States
than the U.S. Copyright Office.
Despite the critical nature
of the services provided
by the Office, the Office
has failed to keep pace
with technology and
the marketplace.
To be clear, this is
not the fault of past
or present Registers
or the Office itself.
Many of these deficiencies
are the result of years
of budgetary neglect
and structural deficits
that have made it impossible
for the Office to keep pace.
In fact, if you look deeper into
these problems, it's evidence
that many of the
challenges confronted
by the Office can be
traced back to the fact
that the Copyright Office is
within and under the direction
and supervision of the
Library of Congress.
The Copyright Office must be
able to rapidly adapt to ensure
that it can offer the tools
and resources that all users
and staff of the Office demand.
And the best way to ensure this
is for the Copyright Office
to have control over
its IT system,
its budget, and its staffing.
Thankfully, there is a
growing groundswell of support
for modernization, and
the Copyright Office seems
to be moving in the
right direction
with its recently
released IT plan
that is both forward
thinking and pragmatic.
To the extent we or anyone else
has concerns with that IT plan,
these concerns are not with
the direction of the IT plan
but rather, with how
fast the Office is moving
in that direction.
The sooner newer, improved
systems can be employed
by the Copyright Office,
the sooner the users
of the Office's services
can reap the benefits
of IT modernization,
and we can get closer
to a 21st century
Copyright Office.
The second issue I'd like
to raise is the possibility
of a small claims process.
It's an unfortunate truth today
that small creators have
rights but no remedies.
They struggle to protect
their copyrighted works
from infringement.
Infringement actions are
particularly troublesome
for visual and literary
artists because of the nature
of their transactions and
the volume of their work.
One reason for this problem is
the excessive litigation costs
required for bringing a
claim in federal court.
We need to fix this.
One way to do that
is for creators
to bring small infringement
claims before a Copyright Office
small claims tribunal,
instead of it having
to go to federal court.
And that's something
we should make happen.
The last issue, before we get to
the panel and other speakers --
the last issue I'd like
to raise is commonly --
what is commonly referred to
as the "all vid proposal."
The all vid proposal is
a proposal by the FCC
that will require cable and
satellite TV distributors
to allow third parties
to provide subscribers
with their own set
top box through which
to access the TV programming
that is licensed to the --
by the TV distributor.
While this might sound
innocuous and even laudatory,
the all vid proposal does not
merely allow third parties
to sell TV subscribers a
cheaper or better set top box.
What it does is allow that third
party, who has not paid a dime
to license the copyrighted
TV programming,
to offer their own
commercial video service
that includes that programming.
In other words, the all vid
proposal will create a class
of free riders that don't
have to pay for TV programming
but are allowed to
make money from it.
The primary form of compensation
for creative professionals
responsible
for the video content --
the directors, the writers,
the designers, the actors,
composers, costume makers,
visual effect specialists,
film crews composed of grips
and cameramen -- they're all
governed by complex contractual
or collective bargaining
agreements that provide
for residuals, participation
rights,
or contributions toward
health and pension benefits.
By allowing the distribution
and public performance of video
and entertainment works
outside of these agreements,
the FCC is undermining
the system
by which creators
are compensated
and harming the very people
responsible for the works
that consumers want to watch.
While the Copyright Alliance
encourages the development
of new technologies to bring
licensed works to the public
in new and innovative ways,
we are gravely concerned
that the FCC's proposal
will permanently
and significantly harm these
creative professionals.
And so with that, you've
heard enough from me.
I will turn things
over to Maria.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Keith.
Thank you for not saying
anything controversial.
World IP Day, of course,
doesn't come together in a --
with a wave of a magic wand.
So I want to thank a few people,
if you could raise your hand.
From the Copyright Alliance:
Sarah, Eileen and Claudia.
And from my team:
Syreeta Swann - so shy.
Syreeta is in the very back.
So thank you.
Thank you, guys.
In putting this event together,
I also want to thank those
of you who are
from organizations also putting
together IP events today,
and also, we're very
sensitive to the fact that many
of you are running
from event to event.
We tried very hard to
schedule our event at a time
that would not conflict
with other events.
We weren't entirely
successful there,
in part because of Chairman
Goodlatte's schedule,
in part because of the flights
of our extraordinary
artistic talent that has come
into D.C. today to be with you.
So, as it turns out, Chairman
Goodlatte has pre-recorded his
remarks today so that we could
hold this event in the morning
to make sure that we had all
of our artistic team here.
And I'll introduce
him in a moment.
What I wanted to say,
though, is that if you go back
to Copyright Review three years
ago, you know that the advice
of the Copyright
Office to Congress was
that the time had come for them
to step back and look at all
of the different
issues that a variety
of stakeholders were
putting forward
as the singular most
important issue or, in fact,
the issue that Congress
should stay away from
and let the marketplace handle.
And our advice to
Congress was that Congress
and Congress alone has
the role constitutionally
of balancing all of those public
equities and stepping back
and then deciding whether to
act or whether to revise the law
or whether to monitor
marketplace developments,
all of which are the
domain of Congress.
In making that recommendation,
we noted that in order for that
to happen, you need to have
committee leadership in Congress
that has a meaningful degree of
fluency in the Copyright Act,
as well as a staff committed
to that committee or committees
that also has a meaningful
degree of fluency
and a commitment to
keep copyright moving
from session to session.
And as such, we were
absolutely pleased
that Chairman Goodlatte first
put Copyright Review before the
Subcommittee on Intellectual
Property and then moved it
to the full committee
level, where it still is,
and as we move to the
next session of Congress,
I just want to make sure that we
all thank him for stepping back
and running such an
incredibly transparent
and comprehensive process.
And you're probably
wondering what's next.
And I think you'll find that
in his recorded remarks,
he answers that question.
So although he's not here,
let me introduce him.
Some things you may
not know about him.
So you know that
he is the Chairman
of the House Judiciary
Committee.
How many of you knew that he is
the first Judiciary Committee
Chairman from Virginia
in the last 125 years?
Raise your hand if
you knew that.
That's an extraordinary fact.
The House Judiciary
Committee, aside from looking
at copyright law, is at
the forefront of some
of the most significant
issues of the day,
including protecting
constitutional freedoms
and civil liberties, oversight
of the U.S. Departments
of Justice and Homeland
Security, legal and regulatory,
[inaudible] innovation,
competition and antitrust laws,
terrorism, crime,
and immigration.
Many of these issues will
be the deciding factors
in determining the future
direction of our nation.
The jurisdiction
of the Judiciary Committee
is well suited to many
of Bob's legislative
priorities, which are IP,
constitutional rights,
private property,
Second Amendment rights,
securing our borders,
strengthening our criminal
laws, and so forth.
We are indebted, of course,
in the copyright community
for his very forward thinking
and thoughtful leadership,
and without further ado, I'd
like to introduce, virtually,
Bob Goodlatte, Chairman of
the House Judiciary Committee.
>> Thanks for the opportunity to
give remarks at today's event.
Unfortunately, I had a
preexisting commitment
in Charlottesville this
morning that prevented me
from being with you in person.
Three years ago, the
Committee began a process
to thoroughly review our
nation's copyright law,
an overdue effort that
resulted in gathering input
from a diverse range of
copyright creators, owners,
distributors, platforms,
and end users.
Beginning with 100 witnesses
at 20 formal hearings,
the Committee then traveled
to Nashville, Santa Clara,
and Los Angeles for
three public roundtables
with over 60 participants.
Committee staff then followed
up with all prior witnesses
and those who had expressed
an interest in copyright,
to develop a comprehensive
record
of the issues facing the
American copyright system today.
What copyright issues did
the Committee hear about?
More than most could imagine.
Some of the topics included:
In what ways can consensus be
achieved in copyright policy?
How does copyright
and technology create
innovation in America?
What is the proper role
of voluntary agreements
and how can they be encouraged?
Does the scope of copyright
protection need updating?
Does the fair use balance,
as it exists today,
reflect congressional intent
when it was first codified?
Is section 512 working well
for all interested parties?
Are bad faith actors abusing
the notice and takedown system?
Does U.S. law create the proper
framework for the preservation
and reuse of copyrighted works
that are either deteriorating
or lacking copyright
ownership information?
Is the current compulsory
video license framework the
best approach?
How is first sale
working in a world
of mixed and digital goods?
Does the music licensing system
work to the detriment or success
of musicians, and is the
current compulsory license
system working?
Is the termination rights
framework too complicated?
Does the U.S. need greater moral
rights or a resell royalty?
Does the current remedies
framework reflect an appropriate
balance between providing
compensation for damages,
for actual losses, while
deterring future infringements?
Does this same remedies
framework provide a meaningful
enforcement right for
smaller copyright claims?
Do the anti-circumvention
provisions
of Chapter 12 efficiently
determine exemptions
for adverse effects
on non-infringing uses
or for security and
encryption research?
Are the needs of the visually
impaired community being met?
What is the impact of current
copyright law upon students,
professors, and their
academic institutions?
Is the Copyright
Office functioning well
in its present framework, or
is there another framework
that would work better?
What are the resources and
information technology necessary
for the Copyright
Office to function well?
While not all of these questions
are of interest to everyone
in the copyright system,
they demonstrate the
interconnected nature
of U.S. copyright law.
Simply changing a paragraph
here and a word or two there
in Title 17 may have a
major impact far beyond its
intended approach.
Thus, it is critical
that Congress understand the
overall impact of any changes
in copyright law
before proceeding
with formally introduced
legislation.
It is also clear that neither a
solely copyright owner-focused
bill nor a copyright
user-focused bill could be
enacted by Congress
today nor should they be.
Any potential changes
to copyright law cannot be
based upon mere talking points
of interested parties.
Copyright law, much like
all of the other titles
of the U.S. Code, are
about the details.
Words matter, not bullet points.
In the weeks ahead,
we will identify areas
where there is a likelihood,
a potential consensus,
and circulate outlines
of potential reforms
in those areas.
Then, we will convene
stakeholders for further work
on these potential reforms.
And you have my personal
commitment
that as the review shifts
to more focused work
on potential reforms, the
process will be transparent,
and the Committee will
continue to ensure
that all interested parties
have the opportunity to weigh
in on issues of concern to them.
Our copyright system
deserves no less.
While no one can guarantee
that every interested party
will share the same views
on every copyright policy
issue, I can guarantee
that we will have an open
ear to everyone who wants
to contribute to this process.
All views are welcome.
Thank you again for
the opportunity
to speak with you today.
When our nation's founders
included intellectual property
in our constitution, they
recognized the importance
of creativity to our
nation and our economy.
We need to ensure that our laws
continue to promote creativity
and innovation in
the digital age.
I look forward to working
with you in the months ahead.
>> All right.
So you've heard from
all of us policy
and Washington D.C.-based folks.
It's now time to turn the panel
over to the real interesting
people, the creators
and our creators' panel.
And so I want to introduce our
moderator and ask Devlin to come
on up here and take a seat.
Devlin Hartline is
our moderator.
He is the Assistant Director at
George Mason's Law School Center
for the Protection of
Intellectual Property or CPIP.
At CPIP, Devlin leads
CPIP's communication
and academic advisory
efforts, working closely
with CPIP scholars to publicize
and promote rigorous research
on the law, on economics,
and on history
of intellectual property,
and he also writes a really,
really good blog so you should
check it out at lawtheories.com.
So Devlin, why don't
you come on up?
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning, everybody,
and happy World IP Day.
We have an exciting
panel for you, but first,
I want to thank Register
Pallante for hosting this event,
and I want to thank Keith
and the Copyright Alliance,
and I especially
want to thank Sarah
for organizing the panelists
and handing me all these
fancy questions to ask them.
So, thank you.
So we've got three
creators on our panel today,
and without further ado, I'd
like to get them on the stage
so we could get started.
The first is Jared Geller.
He's the Executive Producer
of the open-collaborative
production company, HITRECORD.
[ Applause ]
Next up is Anna Metcalfe.
She's a ceramic artist and the
founder of the wedding registry,
Gather, which enables guests
to give local art
for wedding gifts.
[ Applause ]
And, last but not least,
is photographer, founder,
and CEO of CreativeLive,
Chase Jarvis.
CreativeLive is the world's
largest live streaming education
company focused on photography,
video, design, music,
and entrepreneurship education.
[ Applause ]
So we're going to start
with presentations
from the panelists, and then
we'll move into the questions.
Jared, you're up.
>> Good morning.
It's so exciting to
be recognized by --
first of all, it's
great to learn
that there was a World IP Day,
so that's just --
happy World IP Day.
But it was really such
an honor to be recognized
by the Copyright Alliance
and by the Copyright
Office to present today.
I actually brought
along two videos.
One to introduce who
we are at HITRECORD.
I think that's probably
the best way to -- yeah --
to explain who we
are and what we do.
So, without further ado.
>> Okay. Recording.
Hello and welcome to HITRECORD.
I'm Joe. I started this
place a long time ago
with my brother, Dan.
And it's a little bit different
than your typical internet,
social network kind of thing.
The point here isn't to keep
in touch with your friends
or to follow celebrities or even
to showcase something
you made on your own.
The point here is to
make things together.
HITRECORD is a new kind
of production company,
and we produce all
kinds of art and media.
We've played short
films at film festivals.
We published books.
We put out records.
We made a TV show that won
an Emmy, and our website
and our mobile app is
designed to allow anybody
to come join this community and
contribute to those productions.
And yes, any time one of
our productions makes money,
the contributors
get fairly paid.
So, certainly, if you are
an artist of any kind,
if you're a writer, a filmmaker,
musician, graphic artist,
photographer, illustrator,
animator, editor,
or anything, come work with us.
Or even if you don't
fancy yourself an artist
but you've got a good story to
tell or just something to say,
that can make a great
inspiration
for one of our projects.
If you've got good taste and
you want to give feedback
on the stuff we're making here,
if you want to curate the things
that you see on here that you
like, that's really valuable.
Or if you don't want to do
any of that, and you just want
to hang out and watch
how it happens
and maybe meet a few cool
people, that's all right too.
But it's really fun
if you join in.
Now, how does this all work?
Where do you get started?
One good place to start is
with what we call
creative challenges.
So this is for those times
when you know you want
to do something creative,
but you don't know exactly
what you want to do.
This site will serve
you up a whole bunch
of different challenges,
and you'll find probably
at least one that inspires
you at that moment in time.
I issue a lot of the
challenges as do the fine folks
who work here in this office,
but anybody can issue
their own challenges.
So, for example, say you
shot a bunch of footage,
and you're looking
for a video editor,
you can upload your raw footage
and then issue a challenge
to editors and say,
"Here's all my footage.
Let's see you guys
cut it together."
Which brings us to remix.
So when you upload
something here,
everybody else has permission
to download it, sample it,
revise it, refine it,
build on top of it,
and upload their new version.
So, for example, say you're
a singer and you're looking
for an instrumental to sing
on top of, there's tons
of great instrumental pieces
of music on HITRECORD,
and you can write a
song on top of that.
If you're an animator, you
can go find an illustration,
download it, put in
the after effects,
and turn it into
some kind of cartoon.
Writers, you know that good
writing is in the rewriting.
So if you see something on
the site that you like --
this is a good piece of writing,
but I have a different
idea for it, do that.
Write a new draft.
Punch it up.
Add some jokes.
Change the ending.
Think of this as a huge
worldwide writer's room.
So now comes the question:
how does all of that lead
to a cohesive, finished product?
So I, as well as other folks
who work here in this office,
we're always on the lookout for
stuff coming through our site
that we can sort of take to
the traditional marketplace.
Who decides which projects
become productions,
and who has sort of final cut on
how those productions turn out?
It's a simple answer,
and it's me.
I'm the director of
this production company.
But, like every great director
that I've ever worked with,
I know that, as a director,
I'm nothing without the artists
that I'm collaborating with.
Now, like I said before,
when one of our productions
makes money,
we do pay the contributing
artists, and I'm proud to say,
since 2010, we've paid different
contributing artists all
over the world almost
$2 million dollars.
So, I know nobody wants to
join another internet thing.
We all have too many user names
and passwords to remember.
But, all those hours you
spend on the internet can add
up to something, and I'm
really proud of the stuff
that we've made together.
There's more stuff we're making
all the time, and I'd love
for you to be a part of it.
So -- thanks.
[ Music ]
So that's who we are.
So you can imagine that we
spend -- to make all that work,
we spend a lot of time thinking
about copyright laws and terms
of service and licensing
and monetization
and all of those things.
And since we spend so much time
on this and thinking about:
okay, we want to do this,
we want to work with artists
around the world, and they're
contributing their ideas,
their art, their IP.
How do we make sure that
they're represented fairly
and that they're paid fairly
and what we do is
all very transparent?
And so like I said, we
spend a lot of time thinking
about the ways in
which we do that.
So to be recognized by you guys
and actually to get to know some
of the people who are
here in D.C. working
on this stuff is
extremely exciting.
And I -- when I told Joseph
Gordon-Levitt that we were going
to be participating in
this, he was excited,
so we made actually this
video specifically for today.
And yeah, take that away.
>> We're recording.
Hey, everybody.
My name is Joseph Gordon-Levitt.
I work in movies and TV,
and I also started a
company called HITRECORD.
It's an online community
that works together
as a media production company.
Obviously, I'm pretty
interested in the topic
of intellectual property.
I'm glad we're dedicating
a day to talking about it.
I actually think the
way that we figure
out how intellectual property
is going to work today
and especially how it's
going to work moving
in the future is going to be
a huge part of us succeeding
as a -- as a human race.
So one thing I'll say is in the
past, I used to be of one mind,
which is, the whole notion that
information wants to be free
and that anything you can
put into ones and zeroes
because you can just copy it
as many times as you want,
it shouldn't cost anything.
It shouldn't be worth money.
And my mind really changed
a lot a couple of years ago.
And it was largely this one
book that got me thinking
of it differently that
I really recommend.
And the book is called
Who Owns the Future?
And it's by a writer
named Jaron Lanier.
His contention is
that intellectual
property is worth money,
and it has to be worth money
for capitalism to keep working.
Right now, this sort of
notion or you might say,
the myth that intellectual
property is not worth money,
has largely decimated the music
industry, is doing quite a bit
of damage to the field of
journalism, but moving forward,
it could damage so much more
than just those industries.
And another thing
that Mr. Lanier points
out is digital information,
intellectual property,
it is worth money.
It does generate money.
It's just that right now, when
we're sort of under the illusion
that it's free, all
of the money,
all of the value generated by
that intellectual property,
is just going to a few big
internet giants like Google,
Facebook, etc. because
those companies sort
of trade information, getting
information to its consumers
for free while advertising to
them and making tons and tons
and tons of money because
they're not compensating the
people who generated
the information
that they're delivering.
And so the notion that
intellectual property
in the digital form
is not worth money,
that's something I
think we need to sort
of get past and get over.
It has to be worth money in
order for our economy to work.
I'll give you another example,
and that's my company,
HITRECORD.
We make all kinds of things.
We make short films and
music, books, made a TV show,
and our company is sort of
founded on the principle
that yeah, actually the
artists who do contribute
to these things, even
though they're making their
contributions digitally,
they deserve to be paid,
and that if we make
money as a company,
HITRECORD compensates
the artists
and the contributors whose
intellectual property generates
that value.
I'm not saying everybody
should do it this way,
but this is a way that
we have found to work.
Over the last five or six years
that we've been doing this,
we've paid out almost $2 million
to different artists
all over the world.
It's been a beautiful
thing for me.
A lot of people who get paid
from HITRECORD productions
have never been paid
for their art before, and
that's a wonderful feeling.
Even besides the actual amount
of money, just the principle
of getting paid, it
feels validating,
and I think the folks who
do get paid, they deserve
to feel validated because
their contribution helps
to make money.
We designed our terms
of service to do this.
We have a unique legal
agreement that everybody
who joins our site and
contributes to our projects
because they've clicked
a box and they've agreed
to these terms of service,
and this terms of service lays
out this methodology of payment.
That's also important,
having fair
and transparence in
terms of service.
It not only helps the members
of our community who are able
to get paid for their work,
it helps us as a company.
I definitely think the trust
that we earned by having fair
and transparent terms of service
has really benefitted us.
But again, it goes back
to the principle then.
Just because somebody's
contribution is digital,
doesn't mean it's
not worth money.
And if some work that
someone did made money,
then they deserve to get paid.
I'll leave it there.
Thanks for listening.
And again, thanks
for having this day,
talking about intellectual
property.
I think it's something really
well worth talking about.
Thanks again.
[ Music ]
Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
>> Good morning, everyone.
Happy Intellectual Property Day.
I, too, was excited to
find out that it existed.
And I'm super happy
to be here and honored
to have been chosen
to be a part of this.
My name is Anna Metcalfe.
And I'm originally from
Virginia, but in 2006,
I moved to Minneapolis where
I graduated with my MFA
in Ceramics from the
University of Minnesota.
My personal work ranges from
public art, installation,
community engagement,
and dinnerware.
I'm also an educator.
I teach ceramics at the
University of Minnesota,
and I also teach business skills
to artists all over the Midwest
with an organization called
Springboard for the Arts.
I'm here this morning
as one of three founders
of a web-based startup
called Gather Art Registry.
We are in our ninth
month of our first year.
We were friends long before
we were business partners,
and we had a lightbulb
moment one day.
My now business partner, Rachel,
was purchasing a ceramic piece
for me for a friend's wedding.
And as I was wrapping
up the gift
on my front porch,
she made a comment.
"Couples should be able to
register for art they know
and love for their weddings,
and I should be able to buy it
for them just like I can
buy towels and toasters
from Macy's online registry."
I said "Yes, they should.
That should be a thing.
And it should be carefully
curated and presented
to highlight the value of the
art in our community to buyers."
So that got us wondering.
What if it was possible for
people to register for local art
for their wedding, and what
if an online registry platform
could make it really easy
for their friends and family
to buy couples handmade gifts?
And that is how Gather was born.
It combines three
basic ingredients: art,
wedding gifts, and the internet.
We learned how to write a
business plan after that.
We began contracting with local
artists, and in early 2014,
we started Gather LLC.
After an Indiegogo
campaign in late 2014,
we launched our registry
in the summer of 2015.
Now, midway through our
first wedding season,
we're in the process of
adding to our collection
and expanding our audience.
This is an example of a
product page on our site.
To create -- our mission is
pretty simple actually --
it's to create a new market
for artists and their work.
It's to provide a platform
that meets the demands
of a new generation of
shoppers and art collectors.
And it's also to educate new
audiences about the value
of art and handmade crafts.
I personally curate our
collection from artists
from around Minnesota
and Wisconsin.
We offer items like what
you see in this image:
hand forged bottle openers
from antique wrenches,
laser etched coasters,
hand carved mugs,
and original prints.
We also make it possible
for couples
to commission original work
from their favorite artists.
Erin and Jay, who got
married last August,
wanted to commission Minneapolis
artist, Nicholas Harper,
to paint an original
work for them based
on their favorite novel called
Geek Love by Katherine Dunn.
He obliged, and after
reading the book,
he created a painting based
on two of the main characters
who happen to be Siamese twins.
It was a very interesting
collaboration.
This is an image
of the unveiling
that we had last month.
Like any small business, our
path is filled with discoveries
and challenges that lead
us to make adjustments
that benefit both
artists and our customers.
However, like artists, we find
ourselves navigating systems
and structures that
have been constructed
by software engineers
and marketplaces
that don't always take the arts
or artists into consideration.
Our mission is to create
an easy to navigate bridge
between the wedding industry
and the creative work of artists
through an ecommerce platform.
Our challenges are a result of
the potential incompatibilities
between creative
tendencies and audiences
that understand the value
as being produced
by big box stores.
What is true for artists -- that
creativity requires an abundance
of time, the willingness to be
open to unexpected outcomes,
and that innovation
requires constant change --
are actually the very things
that make our mission
challenging in a marketplace
that demands fast turnarounds,
consistency, and predictability.
Where an artist finds
time to be an asset,
our customers are looking for
shortcuts and fast shipping.
Where an artist --
where constant change is a
positive marker for growth
in an artist's career,
our customers are
depending on consistency.
Where artists seek
the unexpected,
our customers don't tend
to appreciate surprises
in the same way.
So our task is to work enough
within systems and the markets
that encourage entrepreneurship
in the arts all while continuing
to support individual artists
to do what they do best.
We are fully aware that our job
is not to convert the masses
into art supporters,
but we are also aware
that even art consumers
live in the same world
that covets convenience,
and we would be foolish
to ignore the opportunities
that the Internet has
provided to small businesses.
Whether that means we have to
tweak the online platform we use
to make it work for original art
or repackage a traditional
concept for our clients,
Gather is a matchmaker
between the arts
and the rest of the world.
Our hope is that
with time and effort,
the systems will be more willing
to accommodate a different
version of productivity
and value as offered
by individual artists.
Thank you all again
for having me,
and happy Intellectual
Property Day.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks, Anna.
Chase, you're up.
>> Got a couple of slides,
couple very basic ones.
Maybe you can skip
to the next one.
Or I'll do that one and then
go ahead and play this video.
This is just a brand
reel of what I do.
[ Music ]
>> This is what we do.
That's incredible.
[ Music ]
>> All right.
So I'm guessing that
by watching that,
you actually have
no clue what I do.
And that's sort of
my point actually.
This is the classic
five paragraph essay
that you learned to
write in college.
I'm going to tell you what
I'm going to tell you,
and then I'm going to tell you
three things, and then I'm going
to tell you what I told you.
So the first thing is that
my goal here is to share
with you all what is
happening on the streets.
We represent a vast sort of
different spectrum of creators.
And it's my hope to come to
Washington and share a message
that the world, the
laws, have to sort
of be consistently evolving.
So the point one here is
that we are all hyphens.
I started out -- first of
all, I dropped out of --
well, I bailed on a career
in professional soccer,
bailed on medical school,
and dropped out of a
Ph.D. in Philosophy.
My poor parents.
Right? In order to
become a photographer.
That's very strange for
the people in my family.
But I was a photographer,
and then I figured out how
to be a photographer, and then
I figured out how to make money.
So I became sort of
a business person.
And then I became a director.
I started directing
videos and short films
and television commercials.
And then I was a guest speaker.
I keynoted all over the world,
and then I was the
author of three books.
In 2009, I created
the first iPhone app
that shared photos
to social networks.
So it was pre-Instagram.
We had millions of users.
And it fundamentally helped
to shape the photo-sharing
economy that you know today.
Now, that was by a photographer.
My photo studio became
a little incubator.
Again, millions of
downloads all over the world,
and that was the App
of the Year in 2009.
That is a fundamental
sort of shift.
So I was a software
developer then.
And that helped me
understand how technology
and creativity can
work together.
So in 2010, we spawned
this little company called
CreativeLive out of a room that
was a third the size of this
with the goal of educating
the world's creators.
So I took an audience of a
million people that I had built
over the course of five years
and put them in connection
with my peers, who are the
best photographic, design,
music educators in the world,
and that company is
called CreativeLive.
Our first class had
50,000 people in it.
And today, we're the largest,
live streaming education
company in the world.
We reach millions of
creators all over the world.
We've raised about $40 million.
We've had more than
two billion minutes
of creative education
consumed on a video platform.
So what am I now?
Am I a CEO?
Am I a founder?
Am I a company guy?
What am I?
The point is we're all hyphens.
There's like 15 different
things,
and we used to be just one
thing, and now, we are many.
So that's point one.
I'm going to show
a little video.
This is a thing that
just dropped yesterday.
It's a little bit of
an idea of who we work
with at CreativeLive
and what we do.
So I've got one more
video here actually.
Where's that?
Go ahead and play this
video if you would.
[ Music ]
>> Hey everybody.
How's it going?
I'm Chase Jarvis,
photographer, founder,
and CEO of CreativeLive.
At CreativeLive, we believe
that there's creativity inside
of every person regardless
if you're an artist,
an entrepreneur, a
teacher, any profession.
The hard part is unlocking
that creativity and inspiration
and taking real action
every day.
To help with that, I'm
super excited today
to announce a new series
of videos that's going
to help you live your dreams
and career, hobby and life.
That series of videos is
called Thirty Days of Genius.
[ Music ]
This is certainly
the most exciting
and inspirational
series of videos
that CreativeLive has ever
made and definitely one
of the most exciting things I've
personally ever been a part of.
Signing up is super easy.
Go to
creativelive.com/30daysofgenius.
That's number 3-0,
days of genius.
Click that blue button, and
then every day you'll get one
of these videos in your inbox.
These videos are the
things that are going
to help you make a change that
you want to see in your life.
[ Music ]
>> So again, what are we?
We're all hyphens.
That was a program that
just dropped yesterday.
There's already 7,000 students
registered for that class.
And over the course
of the next month,
I bet we'll see 100,000 students
registered for this class.
And those are just your
creators down the street.
This isn't just teaching
about wedding photography.
We absolutely -- we have the
best curriculum in the world
for that, I believe, in
photography, design, filmmaking.
And we teach people real
business skills too,
which is something that
art school does not do.
But I mean, you see names like
Richard Branson, Jared Leto.
This is a global
community that cares
about the future of creativity.
Now, point two is that we
are creating differently,
faster than ever before.
So this is a very risky
thing what I'm about to do,
but there's risk in creativity.
I don't know if we can
do this in Washington,
D.C. There's a lot of suits.
I've heard from many people
say they're not creative.
But we're going to try
and actually do something
real quick here.
First of all, I'm
going to surprise her
and take a picture
with the Register.
All right.
So we're creating a
photograph together.
Now, this is the
riskiest part of all.
I'm going to ask that
you guys do something
that you were not
prepared to do today,
and I'm going to record it.
I'm going to make a little video
on a thing called Snapchat.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
So, this is a serious endeavor.
I need serious faces.
Put your laptops down
for a second and join me.
I'm serious here.
This is -- I want you to do
this for like 15 seconds.
Okay? Can we do this?
You don't even know
what you're going to do
so it's hard to say yes, right?
So join me in clapping.
Okay, ready?
[ Clapping ]
OK. Well done.
So what have we done?
Right now, we have
taken a photograph.
We have just made a
video on my Snapchat.
You don't even know
what that is yet,
but we made a video together.
We collaborated.
This is how creators
are working these days.
In terms that used to be --
that's not the only
way they're working,
but these are just new
ways that we're working.
So in, say, a film production,
those schedules are
weeks, months, years.
The new schedule for creators
are minutes, hours, days.
And the laws that we have,
they don't address that.
Now you can be saying -- that's
just -- this is just child play.
Snapchat is a thing that
my 14-year-old uses.
I could get paid a
lot of money for this.
And people do.
10, 20, 25 grand.
I don't think there's
a person in this room
who wouldn't want 25 grand
for creating the thing
that we just created together.
So my point is that
things are different.
And we need laws, and we need
mentality that can address it.
So that's point two.
And point three is that
we all have real reach.
I'm going to push that thing
out, whether you like it or not,
to two million people.
The irony is not lost on me.
It is absolutely a point
that I'm trying to make.
I had the good fortune of being
at the White House yesterday --
last week with President Biden.
And he hosted -- sorry,
Vice President Biden, yeah.
He won't mind.
Obama doesn't care
about that stuff.
Regardless of what side
of the aisle you're on,
I had the good fortune of
being with Vice President Biden
and some other influencers,
whatever that term mean.
And they were YouTube
influencers,
and Biden made a
really important point.
And that point was,
hey, a couple weeks ago,
I was at the Oscars,
and I made a speech
about the campaign called
"It's On Us," ending assault
on women and vulnerable men.
And it's a very powerful
campaign that I'm very proud
to be a part of, but he said
something to the eight of us,
it was really -- it struck me.
It was like, "I was on Oscars,
and the reach of that is
about 30 million people."
The audience that we
have collected here
in this room today, the eight
of you, you have a reach
of 40 million people
on a daily basis.
So what we are doing is
we are sharing at scale,
without permission, differently,
faster, I would say,
more effectively,
than ever before.
So, I promised a
five paragraph essay.
I told you what I was
going to tell you.
I'm telling you these three
points, and now I'm very,
very excited to sit down
here and talk with my sort
of esteemed colleagues about
what the future of creativity,
specifically, digital
creativity,
means and how it's different.
I appreciate your time.
I'm Chase, and I
just hit my mic.
I'm going to do it one more
time because it's cool,
and so remember, it's different,
it's faster, and we need laws
and mentality to address it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Chase.
And thank you everyone else.
Those were great presentations.
So I want to start with asking
you guys the same question,
and then we'll move to
the individual questions.
And so my first question is -
I just want to give the audience
some background information
about you.
And could you tell
everybody what is it
that brought you to the arts?
And I'd like to start with Anna.
>> Gosh, I actually didn't
consider myself an artist
for a really long time.
There is something intimidating
about calling myself an artist.
And I think it was probably
when I went to graduate school
to get my Masters of
Fine Art that I decided
to call myself an artist.
But I think ultimately,
it wasn't even a
choice that I made.
It was simply making
the inevitable choice
and material -- I'm a
ceramic artist, and so,
getting my hands actually in
material, transforming material,
fire, and food -- those kinds of
things have always compelled me,
and I think, will
probably continue
to compel not only
the work that I make
but then also how I
connect with communities,
which I think is truly
what now compels me
about being an artist,
which is communicating
and effectively giving voice
to a lot of different people.
>> Great, thanks.
Chase?
>> I'd love -- I'll
reference two words,
sort of community and voice.
That was really important to me.
I felt a dramatic pressure,
and I don't think it
was family specific.
Maybe a little bit, but when
I was growing up, it was -
"the creative kid"
was a weird moniker.
And so I ran the other way.
I became the captain
of the football team
because I wanted
to sort of fit in.
I ended up going to college
on a soccer scholarship,
but my whole sort of being was
in conflict, and ultimately,
the ability to create
something is a thing
that is uniquely human.
It differentiates us from almost
every species on the planet,
the ability to have a voice
for underserved community,
for connection, for empathy.
To me, that was something that
if I could figure out a way
to get paid would make
this a life worth living.
I think again I referenced
earlier people saying
in this room that they don't
think of themselves as creative.
Everything in this room -- it's
a pretty beige room honestly -
but was created by no
one who was no smarter
or no creative than anyone else.
It's really about
unlocking that creativity.
And if I could play a role in
that for myself and ultimately,
I've learned later in my
career, that's what I want to do
for others, that it would
be a life well lived.
So it's sort of a calling but
more than anything, an awareness
that this is one of
the reasons we're here.
>> Great. Jared, what
brought you to the arts?
>> I was really fortunate
enough to grow up in New York,
and my parents took me to live
Broadway shows when I was a kid.
And being in the audience
and being in the same room
with the audience and the
performers at the same time
and feeling what they're
feeling at the same time,
it felt like I was a part
of it, because I felt
like if I wasn't here, maybe the
performance would be different.
And so from the very early age
I wanted to always be a part
of that feeling, being a
part of sharing ideas and art
in such a visceral
and immediate way.
And I started working
out in theater.
I worked off Broadway
shows as a --
doing anything that I could
do just to be a part of it.
And I worked as a P.A.,
and then a stage manager,
and then I just started
producing my own shows,
and so yeah, and I think that
actually having a background
with live and experiencing
things live
and immediately really
speaks to what we're talking
about here today with
the digital format
because what we do,
like Chase said,
he's going to push this out,
something that we made together
to two million people,
and that's exciting.
And the fact that we can share
that together is inspiring
and really exciting to me.
>> Great. So the rest of
my questions are aimed
at one particular person, but
if the other panelists want
to jump in, feel free.
So, Chase, I'm going
to start with you.
You created an online classroom,
bringing together creators
with the world's top
experts in their fields.
And what is it about the current
creative economy that led you
to develop this dynamic website?
>> Oh, man.
There's a -- it's a
convergence of many things.
I like the question
because it addresses a --
what I think that is there's
a real need and a vacancy,
that we value creativity.
Look at all of the
industry around creativity.
As I mentioned earlier,
everything in your
world was designed.
It was first concepted
by an artist before
it was manufactured.
And there's a real
disconnect between --
we throw around words like
innovation and creativity,
but we don't know
what that means,
and we don't know
where it comes from.
Well, it comes from
fostering and nurturing that.
And we can't have a culture
that values it, but a system
that doesn't provide for
it, which is currently --
the education system is very,
very broken in our country.
One of the first things to
get cut, the arts programs.
And so, I recognize
that, and with a bunch --
to be crystal clear, it's myself
plus it's a hundred other people
who go to work at CreativeLive
every day with the vision
of helping people
live that life.
And there's another disconnect
around sort of the ability
to make a living and
a life as a creative.
We talked about this
last night at the bar.
I don't know if I'm
supposed to say that.
And it's -- art school
currently does not create --
there's no part of the
curricula that has anything
to do with the business.
And so at CreativeLive, we
wanted to connect millions
of creators all over the
world who are interested --
and these are people who
are going not just from one
to ten in their career.
They're already identified
as a creative,
and they're becoming
more creative,
or they're having a
more successful career,
but these are also people who
are going from zero to one.
These are people who
are working at Amazon
or in an accounting firm,
and they've been
told their whole life
that they weren't creative.
My Mom is a great example.
Told her whole life
she wasn't creative
and then I gave her an iPhone,
and with that little
app I created in 2009,
and she went instantly from
being not recognized as creative
to the most creative
of all her friends.
"Joy, your pictures
are incredible."
Now, those two communities
are both underserved.
So by creating CreativeLive,
we were hoping to sort
of support that, support the
areas, the gaps in our culture
that were missing at this
point, and teach them how
to make a living and
a life from people
who are actually doing it.
This is not an academic
institution.
It is very much a practical,
hands-on, skill-based learning.
And when you have instructors,
who are world-class experts,
and I'm talking -- I mean,
you saw the list of names:
Pulitzer Prize winners, New
York Times best-selling authors,
Grammy award winners,
Oscar award winners.
These are people
that are coming back
and giving back to
their community.
They're also getting
compensated, but to me,
that's a gap in the
sort of marketplace
and intellectual cultural
space that we needed to fill.
>> Great, thank you.
Jared, some other questions.
So what first sparked
your decision
to explore online collaboration
and use digital tools
to create and distribute works?
>> It's funny.
There was no decision really.
This was something that,
especially for me, well, for me,
personally, was something
that just happened
pretty organically.
Like I said, I have a background
in live shows and live art.
And I had worked on a play
with Joe Gordon-Levitt.
And I think it was about ten
years ago, he put this --
this is before YouTube.
So, I guess, it was
more like 11 years ago.
He put up an online
journal called HITRECORD
where he thought, "A lot of
people know me as an actor,
but they don't know
me as a writer.
They don't know me
as a musician."
And so he put up a journal,
a blog that would --
he would put up writing, and he
would put up video and music,
and people would download it.
This is before click-to-play
video.
And a community started
to crop up.
People were writing to him what
they thought about his art,
and then it became a little
bit more of a dialogue,
and Joe would respond to
what people were saying.
And then I remember he made a
very crucial decision as to:
do we put up a message board?
Do we put up a message board so
people can talk more, faster,
and the dialogue can
just get more specific?
And it was a big decision, and
he put up this message board.
And what we -- what started
happening almost instantaneously
was not, "Hey, I'm going
to put this thing up,
and then you respond to it."
It was -- there was a natural
progression that people wanted
to start creating together.
And on this message board
with just a few hundred people
at the start, the very first
collaboration that we had
or that was up on the message
board was a word association
game where somebody
would say a word
and then another person
would say the first thing
that popped to mind.
And then that evolved into
thousands and thousands
of words, and then
somebody had the idea,
"Let's take all these words
and make a story out of it."
And so I think people
have the natural tendency
to want to create together.
And after more and more of
these threads with different --
there was a writing
collaboration
and a music collaboration
and a video collaboration --
we started talking
and said, there's --
people want to do this.
Let's provide a --
we've got to create --
we're developing this
creative community
and sometimes providing
some creative direction.
How can we really make --
turn this into something where
we're making real productions,
authoring in terms of service,
making it legal and
paying people?
And that's what we did,
and starting in 2009,
we started building
the tech infrastructure
and the legal infrastructure
to do that.
So, I mean, just to answer
your question more succinctly,
it wasn't a decision as much as
it was a natural progression.
And I think that's what makes
our community so special is
that it wasn't -- it's
not a marketing campaign.
It's not something
that we forced.
If you were to say how do
you make an online community,
I wouldn't be able to answer it.
But yeah.
>> Great, thanks.
Anna, so what are some of
the challenges that you faced
when trying to connect
with your audiences?
People looking for
wedding gifts,
but they've never
heard of Gather?
>> Yeah. Well, I think it's
kind of a two part answer.
One is it boils down to sort
of straight up marketing
and the ability to just get
a product out into the world.
We have lots of mechanisms
to do that.
Right now, I think
the most exciting part
about our business model
and the way that we do it is
that there's this whole industry
where people get
hitched all the time.
And there's a gift economy
associated with getting married.
And so when two people decide
they're going to do that,
they send out our information,
as any kind of wedding registry
or any kind of ecommerce
platform at this point, to 250,
300 of their favorite friends.
And so those people are really
doing our marketing for us,
which is actually
kind of a cool thing.
I think -- and so I think our
challenge is to get the interest
of that original couple, the
sort of -- our original client,
if you will, and one of the
things that is really exciting
about that is that they
tend to be younger,
and they tend to be interested.
They have all of the towels and
the toasters that they need.
And so they tend
to be interested
in doing something unique
and so when we intersect
with those couples, the
people who are interested
in registering with Gather
or anybody who's interested
in setting up a gift registry
for that matter, it's a matter
of communication, and I
think that's the second part
of it is how do we effectively
talk about value and curation?
What is it that makes the artist
that we represent excellent?
I think the idea of excellence
is something that we --
is a conversation
that is evolving
as we put our work
out into the world.
How do we curate and how do
we consider different works
of art to be excellent?
And we really work hard on
trying to communicate that gap
between what are the --
I have this user experience
when I go into Macy's online.
I'm going to pick on Macy's.
Their online registry page.
I feel like that's the kind of
user experience I want to have,
and so does that --
can that translate
into bringing the fine
art object to my life?
And our task is to
say yes, it is.
There are some things we
have to negotiate, but --
and effectively communicating
those differences is really kind
of our challenge.
Yeah.
>> All right, thanks.
Chase, there's a lot of
talk in the arts community
about finding ways to support
artist-centered technologies.
What's the value in artists
developing their own online
platforms to distribute
and make creative content?
>> Well, it's the first time
in the history of the world
that we are not bound
by gatekeepers.
We require no permission
now to share at scale.
It used to be we were kept
out by the gallerists,
by the photo editor,
by the art director,
or the creative director
at the agency.
And now with the benefits
of technology, you can reach
that same scale or much greater,
as in my earlier example,
at the push of a button.
So what that creates is in
many ways a sense of freedom.
And the technology -- the sort
of technology community --
I don't want to put
crosshairs on their back.
I think Joe is wise to point
out that Google and Facebook
and others are making billions,
hundreds of billions of dollars.
But the message isn't
that they should not exist
or that we should
continue on the paradigm.
It is a very, very dynamic
and complicated thing.
For me, technology
literally created my career.
I was a very sexy?
I was a very sexy photographer.
I was a very successful
photographer pre-internet
because I learned the
value of my work early,
and that was out of necessity.
I needed to eat.
I needed to put food
on the table
so I'm not naturally
gifted in business.
I had to become that.
And I was very happy
with my career and then
in a pre-YouTube -- it was
called Google Video at the time,
where you could put up videos,
I started telling the story
of what I call the black
box of photography.
It was a very closed
world, and if you were
out there sharing a point
of view, you were sort of --
the industry or the people that
were comprised of the leaders
in the industry were
very upset with you.
I was vilified, in fact,
for sharing the first videos
that I was -- about what it
was like to go on location.
It doesn't matter -- I
was shooting for the Nikes
and the Apples and Fortune 100
brands, and telling the story
about what it was like to
do that, effectively opening
up this sort of black box,
and sharing secrets was
a very risky proposition,
and you might be sitting in
the audience judging, thinking,
"Well, geez, why aren't
you undermining your
own livelihood?"
But the reality is
that we need to --
there needs to be some sort of
middle ground between pretending
that that doesn't exist, a
head in the sand mentality,
and acknowledging
that information is moving
faster than ever before.
So it was my very proactive
decision to sort of open that up
and to help other
people become --
I wanted to take a world of
just millions of photographers
and make it into a world of
billions of photographers.
And make the image more
popular than the word.
And that again may
be controversial,
but that enabled -- that was
only enabled through technology.
And my career was able to
grow very, very quickly
when that sort of
paradigm flipped
because no one was
using the medium.
So I sort of stepped
into a vacuum.
And this isn't just about me.
This is about so
many of the other --
I will call them thousands
if not millions of creators
who have been able
to now make a living.
I mentioned earlier
that there are people
who will pay 20 thousand
bucks for the little video
that we made right there.
Maybe not that one because that
was pretty boring honestly.
But the point is that
there is a new economy,
and we are experiencing
seismic shifts
in how the technology world
and the creative
world are interacting.
I think it's, by and large,
up to us to define whether
that will be positive or not.
>> Great. So, Jared.
Your organization is
unique to say the least.
And I'm wondering why do you
use non-exclusive licenses
and why do you invite
creators to the table
to discuss revenue sharing?
>> So, I think the internet
can be, probably is,
a very scary place, and when --
every so often when a social
network you're on, like Facebook
or Instagram, updates
their terms of service
and certain elements are
revealed that organizations want
to make money through
your IP in certain kinds
of ways, we all freak out.
We're very transparent
with our --
with what we're doing
at HITRECORD.
It's very important to create
a really safe environment
if you're going to
create art together.
So we're very clear
and transparent
with what it is we do and
how it is we make things.
And that really -- and if
you're going to do that
and you're going to have that
dialogue, it has to be fair.
And we're very active
with that dialogue.
In terms of non-exclusivity,
we want you to be able
to use your IP to do
whatever you want to do.
We don't want to own it.
We don't want to
control your ideas.
But we are a for-profit
organization so if we can figure
out a way to make money with
your ideas in combination
with everybody else's ideas,
there needs to be some
sort of agreement.
And so we enter into that.
And when we talk about
profit sharing, we've --
as Joe mentioned in the
video -- we've paid out --
at the end of this
year, it'll be closer
to 2.5 million dollars.
And when we were thinking of
our terms of service and laying
out our monetization policy,
we wanted to make it efficient
and just make a formula
or create an algorithm
and just say, "All right,
that's how you get paid."
But it's not -- that's
not how it works.
Every piece of art is different.
Every ingredient to that
piece of art is different.
And how you feel about that
So what we do is every pay
period, we take the money
that was made for that project.
We post those profits on the
site for everybody to see,
and we say, "These are
all of the elements
that went into this project."
Whether it's a music video,
whether it's a television
episode,
whether it's a TV commercial,
whether it's a vinyl record.
We say, "These are all the
things that went into it."
And this is what we think is a
fair split amongst everybody.
And the community has two weeks
to have an open dialogue
about that.
Now, we've been doing
it for six years.
So there are pretty much --
a lot of the question marks
and variables as to how this
would work in different cases,
there's a precedent for it.
But for two weeks, we
have an open discussion.
Some people say,
"You forgot me."
Or, "Maybe I should get more."
Or, this person may be, "I
want to give mine to this."
And we have that discussion.
And at the end of two
weeks, we say, "Okay,
we take that feedback
into consideration,
and then we make a decision."
And what we have found is
that people, of course,
love getting paid and
recognized for what they do.
But I should say the attribution
and the credit is almost
as important, if not more
important, just that people know
that they got credit for
what their contribution was.
What's really great --
and I think there's videos
of Joe signing checks.
I mean, it's more automated
now, but it is really gratifying
to have -- to see a stack of
checks go out to thousands
of artists all over
the world for stuff
that we've made together
and feeling good
that everybody feels good.
Not only about the stuff that
we've made, but about how --
what they were paid
and how they were paid.
>> Great, thanks.
So, Anna, the nature of
Gather is local and intimate.
And so presumably that affects
the way that you can scale.
So I'm wondering, how do
you think of it as an asset
and how is it a limitation?
>> Yeah, that's such
a good question.
And I think we are in such
beginning stages of our business
that it remains to be seen
how that's actually going
to play out.
But I do think that first
of all, the localness,
if you want to call it that,
of Gather is truly an asset
because it allows people to --
and I think people
have this compulsion --
I know in Minnesota this is the
case anyway, to want to dig deep
into something really
close to home
that when we feel really
good about spending dollars
from an artist like two
blocks from our house
or we feel even better
when we realize
that our contribution went
to creating a commission
that would never have happened
without my small
little contribution
from the artist in northeast.
So I think there's something
really gratifying about that.
I also think that it
helps really create,
generate an audience
that has the capability
of transforming individual
artist's lives.
So that there's truly
a mechanism
by which the community can
impact the continued development
of a local arts economy,
which is something
that we think a lot
about in Minneapolis.
So I think that that
is an asset,
and that's really something that
we want to promote and foster.
I imagine that Gather will begin
to extend, and we already kind
of do between Minnesota and
Wisconsin, that there's kind
of an upper Midwestern region
that we'll be really kind
of focusing on developing.
And as far as scaling
beyond that, I think there's
that compulsion exists
in other communities.
And so the way that we
imagine expansion is
to actually franchise
in kind of a weird way,
but to have individual artists
and kind of groups of people
to curate because I think
curation is really essentially
to our process as well.
But to curate a similarly
locally-based version of Gather
in different corners of the U.S.
So we're not sure how
that's going to happen.
We're kind of like trying
to dig deep right now
into the Minneapolis, St. Paul,
and bigger Minnesota market.
But I think it has
a lot of potential.
Like I said, people really
do like supporting local.
And also being able to kind of
point at something on their wall
and say, "Not only
is that a cool piece,
but it's from across town.
I actually met the
person that made that."
And there's just like a lot
of warm fuzzies about that.
So we want to continue
to promote that.
>> Sure. All right, thanks.
Chase. CreativeLive enables
revenue stream for creators
who are also educators by paying
instructors to teach courses.
So what philosophies do you
have in selecting and working
with these instructors?
>> I'll borrow your term.
Curation. It's absolutely
critical that the people
that are teaching at
CreativeLive are the best.
There are many sort
of marketplaces,
online education marketplaces
-- I don't need to name them.
The way I describe it, though,
is they're an inch
deep and a mile wide.
And they really don't care
who's on their platform.
It is sort of something that
was by and large created in a --
I know most of these companies
very intimately and they,
by and large, were created
by MBA's with business plans
to scale online education.
We consider ourselves very,
very focused on creativity.
Photography, design, video,
music and audio, crafts,
the maker movement, and the
ability to make a living
and a life, and all
those things.
And so for us, we want
to serve a community,
a community of creators
who are going
from zero to one or one to ten.
And in that world, our name, our
brand, the value that we bring
to our students is all we have.
And so taking that
lightly would be something
that I wouldn't advocate as the
founder and CEO, and deciding
who gets to be the people
who teach our future
artists is a thing
that we don't take lightly.
We take that very, very
seriously because we're trying
to arm these creators with
the skills that they need
to go into the future.
And we're all literally
assembled here on World IP Day
because the future
is so uncertain
and we need the stewards
of our future to be people
who are validated, who are
carefully curated to sort
of help the rising tide
float all the boats.
So we're meticulous about it.
I wouldn't bore you with the
actual details, but it has to do
with being great at what you do
and also have teaching skills.
It's no different -- think
of the best teachers
-- actually do this.
Think of the best
teachers you ever had.
They were not the smartest.
They were part entertaining,
part wise, very much human,
and those are the people that we
seek to bring on our platform.
So it's not just the
people with the most papers.
It's not the people who
have the most experience.
It's the people who are
great teachers, that connect.
You like to say that there's a
human being behind the pieces
of art, and we want
our instructors,
our experts to be world
class, to be all these things
and to be able to
connect with a community.
So we take that very,
very seriously,
something I'm super proud of.
>> Great, thanks.
Jared, you probably
came to your project
with certain goals
and philosophies.
Has HITRECORD exceeded
your expectations
or taught you new things
about the creative process?
>> Well, yeah.
I think one of the most
inspiring things about HITRECORD
for me is that there's
no end to the creativity
that is contributed every day,
whether that's writing or music
or animation or --
I mean, stop motion,
claymation, all sorts of things.
And what's -- one of the things
that I've learned is the
more people who have a say
and the more people who are a
part of the art that we make,
the richer these stories,
the richer the art is,
the more perspectives.
And we just hear stories that
we just never would have written
ourselves because
we just didn't --
we don't have that experience.
When we were doing the first
season of our television show,
the first episode of our
show was regarding --
we had art and ideas and --
about regarding a
different theme.
Each episode is regarding
a different theme.
And the first episode was
regarding the number one.
And we had a -- we had a -- we
put out a call to action to say,
"Tell us about your -- tell
us your stories regarding your
first time."
And that was your first
time doing anything.
So people wrote all sorts of
stories, contributed stories,
and one girl wrote a
story about the first time
that she saw the stars
when she was 16 years old.
She has a rare eye disorder
where she can't see
pinpoints of light.
And when she was 16, her Dad
bought her night vision goggles
to allow her to see the
stars for the first time.
And that's just a story that
we never would have heard
if we just hired
a bunch of writers
in Hollywood in a writer's room.
But when you have such a
huge community of artists
that are contributing
ideas to these stories,
I think that's the most
surprising thing is every
collaboration that we
do is you never know --
we always have to throw caution
to the wind whenever we --
and can't plan too much
about where we're going to go
with a certain project
because we go
where the community wants to go.
It's where we --
where's the story going?
And I think that's -- again, one
of the most surprising things
and the thing that I
love about creating art
in a digital space is that
you just have the scale
of people with different ideas.
>> That was the last question?
[ Inaudible ]
Okay. All right.
Well, I guess we're
to the last question.
Okay. Can each of you briefly
state what do you think the
future holds?
And let's start with Jared.
>> Future.
>> Future holds.
Specifically, I imagine,
with regards to art making
and the digital space
and copyright.
I think -- first
of all, I think --
and one of the things I was
thinking about on the plane ride
over here was just the fact
that World IP Day exists
and people are learning
more about what that means
and educating artists
as to the value
of their contribution
is a huge step forward
in us not only understanding
what the value of our ideas
in art is but what
we can do about it.
And so I'm -- I think it's
going to be an evolution.
I think there's always going
to be a push and pull and --
but I'm extremely optimistic
just -- and I said it earlier,
but meeting everybody here who
is so passionate about copyright
and figuring things
out with artists,
I think it's a challenging time,
but it's a really inspiring
and exciting time to
be a part of this.
There's -- I think it's --
what a pressing issue and
what an exciting time to help
to start figuring
these things out.
>> Excellent.
Anna?
>> That is such an
amazing question.
>> No wrong answers.
>> Yeah, no.
It's true.
I think about this
a lot actually just
from the perspective of
the other work that I do,
which is to help artists grow
in their own professional
development
and grow their businesses and
grow their living and a life --
that's such a wonderful slogan.
That's what we work really
hard to do at Springboard.
And I think there's this
really interesting tension
between collaboration -- this
is a word that I think all
of us talk about -- and then
also having an individual voice.
And I think that something in
the future will present a "yes,
and" solution to this
tension in such a way
where our human species,
the creativity that happens
when human beings get
together to make art work
and to push our culture forward,
which is truly the most
inspirational thing I can
think of.
When that can happen
and also acknowledge all
of the individual voices that
went into that happening,
and I'm so inspired by all of
the efforts that everyone here
on the stage are
making to do that,
so I think that is an optimistic
what I think will happen
in the future for the arts and
for artists is this, again,
realization of the movement
forward as a collective
and also the individual
voice being recognized.
>> Great, great.
Chase, the future?
>> I'm inspired by
my stage mates here.
I think Jared, you said it well
with -- it's an exciting time.
We used the word tension
a lot last night as well.
I think it is the most
exciting time in the history
of the world to be a creator.
I think there is a tension
around sort of preserving
that in a way that
maintains sustenance
for the people who create.
As the world sort of
commodifies so many things
and goods are being made
cheaper and cheaper all the time
and in many ways, intellectual
property is becoming
commoditized, how do we keep
this from being a problem?
To me, that is a very, very
-- it is the responsibility --
I'm honored to hear that
people love World IP Day.
That you are out there thinking
about that on a daily basis.
I believe deeply that this
is very much a packaging
and an access challenge.
The packaging --
I have litigated against
a publicly traded company.
I want to say thanks to Gene
Mopsik from the ASMP for helping
to support it, five years,
hundreds of thousands
of dollars in costs.
I had a -- it was against
-- I'll just say it,
it was against K2,
a ski manufacturer.
It's a well-documented case.
It was more than
150 infringements.
Cost me five years of my life.
I had to testify in
federal court for three days
by an attorney that was making
12 hundred dollars an hour
to be there.
And that -- we won that case and
had to appeal our own victory
because the judgment was
written in such a way
that it was bad for artists.
So we appealed that, and it
went to the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals where we
won that as well.
And I loved the opening
remarks because if you think
that cost me hundreds of
thousands of dollars in order
to do that, and what
K2, the reason --
I had a voice message that
accidentally was removed
at some point from my message
because it was saved so long
of the vice president saying
really unpleasant things
to me like, "You don't know
who you're f-- - - - g with."
And if that is the plight
of artists going forward,
we're in a real bad spot.
If the people in this room
can usurp that mentality
and if we can through a
packaging exercise of making --
World IP Day is a great
step, but let's make it sexy
to understand that there
is value in our creators.
Let's create access to that
information because access
to information is
really what helps sort
of the tide rise
with all the boats.
By and large, I find that most
of my peers who are struggling
to make a living and a life is
because they either
have not chosen to
or they don't have
an understanding
of access to that information.
So my ask is that that
is what the committees,
the Copyright Office,
Congress consider as their sort
of their future,
their future moves.
It's an incredibly
exciting time.
It's a little bit dangerous,
and I believe our
fate is in good hands.
Good shall persevere.
[ Inaudible ]
>> All right, so we're going
to open it up to the audience
if anybody has any questions.
I believe there are microphones,
so if you could wait
for the mic.
Don't be shy.
>> Come on, you guys.
We came all the way across
the country for this.
>> Now's your chance.
There's a gift for the
first person who asks.
>> Hi. My name is
[inaudible], the US editor
for a magazine called
Music Week,
and I cover copyright issues.
Oh, thank you for the gift.
That's lovely.
I didn't know there was one.
I thought you were just --
The Copyright Alliance
serves a purpose --
there's one thing in the videos
and also in a couple of things
that you said about
information wants to be free.
Isn't there a problem when
every time you mention the work
of art, actually it becomes
information, i.e. one and zero.
And the semantics are important
in a sense that whenever --
and it really used to upset me
when I think information
wants to be free.
Therefore, we can access music.
We can access photography,
etc. These are not --
this is not information.
These are works of art.
So shouldn't we start by
instead of saying information,
saying that these are works of
art and that will help everyone
to actually understand
what it is?
>> To be clear, I was talking
about information in terms
of access to the information
about art, not actually
about art in and of itself.
But I understand very,
very deeply your --
how the challenge exists there.
Again, I dropped out of a
Ph.D. in the Philosophy of Art
so this is really, really
an interesting area for me.
The -- I guess I
don't want to pretend
that it's not complicated.
And if we've had some of
the brightest thinkers
of our times struggling
in politics,
in the Copyright Office, in our
government and governments all
over the world -- if
there's a real challenge
to overcoming these problems,
I don't think one of us
from the stage is
going to answer it.
But let's actually acknowledge
that what you've said
is the central problem.
There really is a gap between
saying well, this is just a mess
and what do we do about
it, and saying actually,
let's identify the problem.
The problem is that is
one very precise problem
that we need to try and solve.
And to say that it's just
too big for us to tackle.
We have a history
in this country.
Our law was created over time.
We didn't just walk out
and say this is the law.
I think I know just a little
bit about the philosophy of law,
and it was created over time,
and it continues to evolve.
We have to put a
stake in the ground
and saying these are a couple
of the central challenges
that we're going
to try and solve.
And if we don't put
a pin in those things
and start working
toward that solution,
we certainly will
never get there.
You know that saying?
If you don't have a
map, you're not going
to get where you're going.
You can't just walk
in the woods.
Or even a broken clock
is right twice a day,
whatever that saying is.
We need to identify the problem.
Keep going.
Come on, you guys.
>> To build upon what you
were saying, there is a --
I think there is a culture
because that is the
central problem.
Well, I'll just share
this music or I have no --
people might be predisposed to
be fine with just taking music
or in essence, stealing music,
because that's just the culture
that we're now living in.
And I think that
you said it right.
All right, now I think it's
really raising our hands
and saying actually
this, understanding
that this is a problem,
understanding that this way
of thinking shouldn't be the way
of thinking and then figuring
out well, how do
we deal with this?
But it is -- I do think that
we are living in a culture
where I think there
are a lot of people
who just think it's okay
because it's so easy.
How could something
so easy not be okay?
So it's identifying that problem
and then figuring it out.
>> And also I think identifying
where there are solutions
already embedded
into that question and the
problem because what I find is
that artists don't --
smaller artists, anyway,
don't tend to have the
problem of too much exposure.
In fact, they really need
more exposure and that idea
of turning what they
do into information
that can be widely distributed
is often times the thing
that gives them the
living and the life
that they can then build upon.
And so, yeah, I think there's --
I'm going to use the word
tension again because it --
certainly -- maybe it's the
two sides of the same coin
that there is the asset
to information going
out to the masses and then
there's also what we have
to do is protect that too.
Yeah.
>> Hi. How would your
company protect --
okay, say if I was to submit
something to your company,
a picture, and how would
you protect that from those
who are trying to make a
income, a passive income?
Say Amazon has a way where you
can copyright somebody's work.
With HITRECORD, how would you
protect the work that I submit?
>> If I'm understanding your --
I don't know the Amazon service
that you're referencing --
if I'm to understand
your question correctly.
If you were to upload a
picture and somebody else were
to download it and try to
make money off of it outside
of the website, actually we --
it gets back to the question
about non-exclusivity.
We don't represent --
if you were to do
that and it happens --
I shouldn't say that
it happens --
I'm not aware of a case where
somebody would download a photo
and make money, but I
know that there are cases
where people would
download art off of our site
and perhaps put it on
Tumblr or on Facebook
and perhaps there's a
monetization stream that way.
But we don't represent
the artists for protection
against that sort of thing.
And if we did, we would then
require the exclusive rights
to your IP because then
we can represent you.
There is an infrastructure
for us to do that.
We essentially have a
license for us to work with
and to monetize along
with other people's art.
So I guess the short
answer is that could happen.
That's for the artist
to represent themselves.
That is to say when people make
us aware that things are going
on with either one
member or a combination --
if somebody takes your
photo and combines it
with another member's photo and
tries to do something with it,
we do make best efforts
to try to make it right.
But at the end of the day,
we don't have the authority
to speak on behalf
of the artists
because we don't have
that kind of license.
>> I think we have to end.
Sorry.
>> Okay.
>> They'll be here briefly, I
think, after the event if you'd
like to talk to them
a little bit.
But would you please help me
thank them for being here today?
[ Applause ]
As Register, I'll
take the liberty
of offering a few
closing remarks.
Just summarizing
what I just heard.
Obviously, being an artist
from what you can tell is an
extremely disciplined craft
and a lifetime craft at that.
I agree wholeheartedly with
Chase and his observation
that you should not, if
you're an artist listening
to this today or will listen
to it later on our website --
don't underestimate
participation
from our nation's artists
in the copyright debates
going on currently.
It would be illogical
to have a copyright act
that does not protect and
support our creative voices.
We're doing our best in
the Copyright Office.
There are many organizations
that obviously agree
with that principle.
Certainly, Congress does, but
they need to hear from you.
I'm tempted to provide the
recommendation to Congress
that they should take
Jared's business model
of giving everybody two weeks
to weigh in on any proposal
that comes off the Hill, and
then they'll make a decision.
I'm not sure it'll go that way.
So instead, I'll end with Anna's
observation that of course,
even in the copyright
debate, there is a tension
between expressing one's
individual goals or perspective
and then collaborating
with others.
And of course, we have
to have both so here's
to working together for the
next great Copyright Act.
Thanks.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.